bienvenue à part à l'automne ici c'est
melissa maulin depuis cette semaine on a
une question de jean luc qu'on va les
écouter ce que les autochtones vont
jamais s'en sortir alors jean-luc qui me
demande si les programmations les
autochtones vont réussir à s'en sortir
et je peux te dire que déjà on le fait
on est encore ici
cinq cents ans après la colonisation
malgré justement les guerres biologiques
malgré les pensiones la loi sur les
indiens toutes les formes de
colonisation qui nous ont été imposées
on est encore ici donc je pense qu'on
commence à prouver qu'on sait s'en
sortir on doit maintenant guérir de
toutes ces attaques là sur notre
identité notre langue notre culture
je pense que comme n'importe quel
citoyen oui on va traîner avec nous ces
savoirs ancestraux parce que comparé à
d'autres savoirs qui nous ont été
imposées ces savoirs là ont fait leurs
preuves
on est dans notre survie est justement
ont aidé à la fierté et justement quand
je vois notre existence aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui nous donne encore envie
d'aller vers l'avant et penser encore au
cette future génération et ce qui est
vraiment heureux c'est que maintenant
beaucoup de gens reconnaissent que de
voir voulu éteindre ces savoirs là ça a
été une erreur que le québec et le
canada les etats unis aussi on fait et
maintenant ils veulent intégrer les
savoirs des premières nations pour ce
qui est de la conservation des animaux
pour ce qui est de la survie dans les
changements climatiques donc je pense
qu'on s'en sort plutôt bien puisqu'il
fait qu'on s'en sort bien c'est que
justement on a encore la main tendue on
est encore connaissant de nos savoirs et
on encore très fiers et qu'on fait cette
transmission là et maintenant on l'a
fait aussi avec la population québécoise
et canadienne
donc j'espère changer que ça n'a pu
aider à ta question pour pour quand même
la grand angle que ça doit couvrir mais
je dirais que plus les gens vont
s'ouvrir aux cultures des premières
nations plus vont comprendre que c'est
pas nous nous a étayé
je souhaite une très belle semaine
n'hésitez pas à partager les vidéos
hésitez pas à nous envoyer des questions
surtout à part un autochtone